the movie opens in Boston where people
are going on with their daily lives all
of a sudden they begin to collapse
inexplicably to the ground causing chaos
the scene then cuts to a geology
Professor Dr Josh Keys who is seen
teaching his students about Soundwave
properties and dense objects the class
is interrupted by some government
officials who ask Josh to accompany them
come with us nerd they escort him to a
secret facility in Washington DC where
he meets his scientist friend Conrad
zimsky who has also been brought here
for a crucial discussion the two of them
are led to a huge room filled with
deceased individuals causing them to
initially think that they're in the
wrong place just then they're greeted by
an army General purcel who informs them
of simultaneous mysterious deaths and
seeks their expertise Josh being a
geophysicist speculates that the people
died of a powerful electromagnetic pulse
as all of them have pacemakers implanted
in their bodies the general is relieved
that it's not an act of War so he
dismisses the case Josh and Conrad
suggest that they delve deeper on the
matter citing the seriousness of the
situation but the unfaced general walks
away get out of here nerds later that
day another strange incident occurs in
Trafalger Square London where hundreds
of birds go out of control and collide
with buildings as well as people
creating Havoc when Josh hears the news
he links the two events eventually
concluding that these incidents are
happening due to the variances in
Earth's electromagnetic field this
variance also has its effect on a US
space shuttle which is making its way
back to Earth their communication with
the control center is disrupted for a
few moments derailing the spaceship
several miles off course LA with only a
couple of minutes left to land the pilot
major Rebecca comes up with an immediate
plan to crash land in a river with no
alternative they proceed with this plan
and somehow managed to do so with a
little harm to the shuttle avoiding a
catastrophic accident after analyzing
the events thoroughly Josh comes to a
troubling conclusion Earth's rotating
molten core is gradually coming to a
stop without its movement the
electromagnetic field around the earth
will collapse within months and expose
the surface to unfiltered solar
radiation ultimately incinerating the
entire planet Josh hurriedly shares his
findings with Conrad who is also left in
shock sensing the gravity of the
situation the high ranking government
officials set up a meeting and summon
Josh to elaborate on his discoveries
Josh breaks down the scenario in
layman's terms AKA for idiots
highlighting its dire implications when
questioned about a solution he asserts
that it's impossible to fix this because
the inner core is surrounded by a super
heated hyper fluid of molten iron and
nickel at 9,000 de F 2,000 M down and
1,000 M thick and the deepest humans
have beenin is 7 miles however Conrad
seems to know someone who can find a way
Godzilla following this Conrad takes
Josh General purcel and a weapon expert
LC to Salt Flats Utah to meet his former
colleague Dr Ed brazzleton turns out
that Conrad had stolen a few research
ideas from him in the past which led to
a falling out between the two regardless
Ed agrees to work with him again if it
means saving the Earth he then
demonstrates his self-made means of
drilling through the Earth at high
speeds using a series of high-powered
lasers he also shows them unobtanium a
material capable of withstanding the
immense pressures deep inside the planet
as well as generating energy from them
as well as making avatars horny after
seeing all of this General cell tells
him to turn his prototype into an actual
spaceship within 3 months and for this
he offers to provide him with all the
resources he needs starting from the
very next day the work begins at a rapid
Pace in the later days NASA Pilots
Commander Richard Iverson and major
Rebecca Childs are enlisted to Pilot the
spaceship in addition to this an expert
computer hacker Theodore Donald Finch is
brought on to keep news of the pending
disaster and their attempt to restart
the core off the internet Twitter can't
handle this one boy this highly
professional team is led by Josh
eventually the ship becomes a snake-like
vessel named Virgil it is made up of
several compartments and will be
launched over the Mariana's Trench in
the Pacific Ocean the deepest point on
Earth if any compartment of the ship is
damaged the operating system will
automatically eject that compartment to
avoid risk to the rest of the ship once
they reach the destination they will
deploy an explosive charge large enough
to restart its core one day the team
notices a massive lightning super storm
in the sky upon checking it on their
system they realized that Rome is its
imminent Target with had a chance to
react the lightning storm results in
multiple explosions leading to the
collapse of buildings and the ultimate
ruin of the entire city and the death of
Mario this incident makes the crew
realize that the planet is decaying
faster than they anticipated and that
they don't have enough time for the
testing phase as a result they prepare
to launch the Virgil right away with six
crew members on board Josh Iverson
Rebecca Conrad and head and laac after
getting everything ready the spaceship
is successfully launched through Mariana
Trench they dive at such a high speed
that they cover 500 km in just a few
minutes the team is relieved that their
equipment is working to expectations
upon reaching a certain depth they are a
struck by the underwater View and the
sharks singing to their sonar radiation
after several hours of their Journey
they penetrate the Earth's crust and
make their way to the semi-solid mantle
as they Traverse the mantle the crew
observes peculiar dark spots in front of
them Josh interprets these spots as
empty areas explaining that the machines
are not programmed to recognize such
void spaces before they can alter their
course the ship drills through a
gigantic empty geode structure crash
landing and damaging its laser drilling
device thankfully no one is injured but
a giant crystal becomes lodged in their
ship preventing it from moving now the
crew has no other choice but to walk out
of the ship and fix the problem manually
Josh Iverson add and levac done their
special space space suits and venture
out of the ship they soon realize that
they are inside a giant gem bubble
wrapped in a Cobalt cocoon despite the
Intriguing surroundings they don't have
enough time to explore the area so they
proceed to carry out the ship repairing
process Iverson begins cutting off the
giant crystal that is stuck in their
ship while the rest of them inspect
other damaged spots during the repairs
the geode gets flooded with Magma and
the crystals Begin to Fall towards them
within a very limited time frame the
crew somehow manages to repair the
spaceship but before they can Retreat a
falling Shard strikes Iverson's head
causing him to fall into the magma and
die despite this heartbreaking loss the
crew has no time for mourning so they
rush into the ship and escape the scene
just before the geode collapses further
down Virgil passes through a vast field
of enormous Diamond formations although
Rebecca manages to dodge a few
formations one of them breaches the last
compartment of the ship housing the
detonation timers for the nuclear
charges despite knowing that the damaged
compartment will soon be ejected from
the main ship laac enters inside it to
gather The crucial nuclear charges he
successfully manages to pass them to his
crew members but he is Left Behind in
the process moments later his
compartment gets ejected and crushed
resulting in his tragic demise this
breaks Josh down in tears but the fellow
members encourage him to stay strong as
they are responsible for saving the
entire planet in the next few hours the
team finally reaches the molten core
after a series of calculations they find
that the core is much less dense than
they expected this means that nuclear
explosives that they're carrying will
not be sufficient to impact the core
confronted with this failure Conrad
suggests that they return back and
initiate Plan B here it is revealed that
the US military had previously received
info about the enemy Nations preparing a
powerful weapon that could generate an
earthquake in order to counter their
attack the US government under the
leadership of Conrad built an even more
powerful tectonic weapon called Destiny
deep Earth seismic trigger initiative it
is also disclosed that the first testing
of Destiny is what caused the core's
rotation to stop and that the government
is the one responsible for everything
now watch my golf swing this Revelation
leaves the rest of the crew in shock but
they have no time to argue on this
matter they refused to carry out plan B
of launching Destiny claiming that there
is a high risk of the Earth being
destroyed instead of restarting the core
they contact the control center to talk
to General purcel who also orders them
to abandon the effort and return
immediately however the crew refuses to
comply and intends to devise an
alternative plan by this point of time a
burst of harmful ultraviolet rays
penetrate the ozone layer and land
straight on the Golden Gate Bridge of
the United States consequently the
bridge as well as the vehicles melt down
and fall into the water this incident
quickly spreads through the news
alerting the world to the situation
because Rome didn't I guess General
purcel can no longer wait and orders the
military team to fire the destiny even
knowing that it could endanger The
Virgil crew back in the spaceship Josh
secretly communicates with Donald and
asks him to buy them some time Donald
then uses his exceptional hacking skills
to redirect power from Destiny in order
to prevent General purcel from
activating it he does so by going like
this on his
keyboard following this the crew starts
discussing their next move Conrad who is
unable to convince the team is forced to
help them with their plan C shortly
after they devise a strategy placing an
explosive in each of the remaining comp
apartments and timing their detonations
in an exact sequence to trigger the
Earth's rotation through constructive
wave interference however there is a
problem the ship system is programmed in
such a way that it ejects compartments
only when it's damaged as a result they
must override the program manually to
carry out their plan further for this
any one of them has to go to the open
area at the front of Virgil which is
exposed directly to the heat of the
molten core amidst this critical moment
ad selflessly volunteers to sacrifice
his life for the greater good of saving
the planet he Dawn his suit and bids a
final goodbye to his fellow crew members
before walking out of the compartment as
soon as the front door opens Ed is
overwhelmed by the extreme heat
instantly burning a tool in his hand
despite the intense conditions he
presses onward and successfully
activates the override system however he
tragically collapses down and succumbs
to the heat in the aftermath the rest of
the crew start mounting the nuclear
charges in each compartment before
ejecting them but when they come to the
last two Apartments they realize that
they still lack enough explosives for
this before they can come up with a
solution the spaceship experiences a
huge shock trapping Conrad and thwarting
the communication system Josh tries hard
to get him out but to no avail since
Rebecca can't hear them anymore she
calculates the time and initiates the
ejection process as a result Josh is
forced to escape the detaching
compartment leaving Conrad behind now
that he is left with no other choice
Josh resorts to using Virgil's nuclear
power source to provide the additional
energy for the final detonation after
ejecting the final compartment he
returns to Rebecca and tells her about
what he did he also mentions that they
no longer have enough power supply to
return home despite this shocking news
Rebecca respects his decision and
Comforts him saying that she would have
made the same Choice while awaiting
their fate an idea strikes Josh's mind
as Virgil is made up of unobtanium it is
capable of generating energy from heat
and pressure with this realization the
duo instantly proceeds to work on
reconfiguring V cover into solar panels
making it absorb all the heat that it
requires much to their surprise the ship
regains its power and activates its
systems soon after the detached
compartments begin exploding one after
another creating a ripple effect that
ultimately restarts the core's rotation
as a result of this the ozone layers
start to replenish and the planet starts
to heal itself moreover the huge blast
propels Virgil out of the core and makes
its way through tectonic plates at high
speed eventually breaching into the
ocean floor near Hawaii now that the
heat and pressure in this environment is
much lower Virgil shuts down for one
last time leaving them stranded
underwater Josh who is still not ready
to give up and is somehow not flattened
by all that speed uses a low power
ultrasound to draw whales nearby the
ship meanwhile the government carries
out the search for the survivors but
initially finds no trace of them not
long after Donald hears the whale sound
which he uses to track down Virgil as a
result the ship is pulled up into the
surface and the survivors are finally
rescued in the final scene Donald is
seen in a cyber cafe from which he
uploads information about Virgil and its
team resulting in the world honoring the
crew as Heroes subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching